future of the internet is here
or is it
so far the web has gone through two
major stages web 1.0 which you may
remember from the 90s was largely a
read-only medium that was a
decentralized collection of static web
pages you could read but you couldn't
easily add your own Voice Web 2.0
changed things up in the early 2000s
taking the internet from a read only to
read write now you could post your own
blog leave comments or more recently
have a Facebook page or Twitter feed
while web 1.0 was sprawling and
disorganized 2.0 was concentrated around
a few large platforms these platforms
owned your posts your data and well you
now web 3.0 or web 3 as it's known
promises to hand some of that ownership
back through tokens and voting rights by
rewriting how the web Works proponents
say it would create a read write own
system built on blockchains which are
shared ledgers or databases
it would in theory be decentralized
Democratic and peer-to-peer the best
known example of what this might look
like is cryptocurrencies including
Bitcoin ether and tether there are also
non-fungible tokens or nfts which allow
ownership of digital objects and
distributed autonomous organizations or
Dows which help groups of people
organize and make decisions instead of
trading their data for free services web
3 users would earn tokens and crypto
coins for their online contributions
like reporting bugs or validating
transactions also called mining they
could then trade these crypto coins and
tokens directly with other users
all of this could add up to a web where
users have more ownership of their data
their online identity and a say and how
the internet actually works it have the
functionality of Web 2.0 and a
decentralization of web 1.0 plus to be
Community Driven and self-governing
sounds neat none of this however is
inevitable despite VC Investments and
bold proclamations there's no guarantee
people will adopt web3's Vision crypto
has major problems with energy
consumption there's a ton of scamming in
swindling it's unclear if these
Technologies can work at a scale and the
blockchain and decentralization might
make Innovation harder so while web3 has
a promise there's also quite a few red
flags